[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK SPATES: Hello
and good morning.
Thank you for
joining our session
to talk about integrating
your Smart Home devices
with the Google Assistant.
I'm Mark Spates.
And I brought a few of
my colleagues with me.
MICHELE TURNER:
I'm Michele Turner.
I'm the director of the
Smart Home Ecosystem.
DAVID SCHAIRER: And
I'm David Schairer.
I lead engineering for Smart
Home [INAUDIBLE] assistant.
MARK SPATES: Awesome.
So when we started this
project a couple of years ago,
we had a vision.
And our vision was to have
the Google Assistant be
the center of intelligent
interactions with IoT devices.
We selected the word intelligent
for a very specific reason.
We believed that
users would demand
that their Assistant
in their home
understand the environmental
context as well as the device
capabilities when they started
to control these devices.
To achieve this goal, last
year, we launched the ability
for developers like
yourself to integrate
Smart Home devices using the
Actions on Google Platform.
Just a quick reminder,
Actions on Google
is our platform for developers
to create experiences
around education,
games, and many others
through the Google Assistant.
When it came to Smart Home,
one thing that we focused on
was having a seamless, easy
experience for developers
to connect these devices
to this Assistant.
We also understood
that we had to allow
this connectual understanding
that we were gaining
from the home and
devices also to be
accessible to our developers.
With that we also
created the Home Graph.
This is a very simple
visual representation
of the Home Graph.
The Home Graph is the key to
these intelligent interactions
that we have with users.
I'll just walk
through it quickly.
If you look at it, it's broken
down into three main parts.
The first part is the structure.
Understanding the structure,
the name of the structure,
the address of the structure.
Who's in the structure?
What rooms are in
this structure?
What devices are
in this structure?
Is there anyone home?
What's the presence
of this structure?
Then the next thing that
we look at are rooms.
Rooms are extremely
important signals
when you think about
interacting with an Assistant
when it comes to
contextual relevance.
A command in a living
room versus the kitchen
can mean very different things.
So when you look
at the room level,
we're saying what is
the name of this room
and what devices
are in this room?
The third and probably one of
the most important components
are devices.
When we look at the
metadata that we
want to get from devices, it's
things like names, type, trait,
attributes, and state.
If you combine these
three elements,
you start to see how we're
building our understanding
and our contextual
relevance to help
users get to the exact
control that they want.
So we launched this last
year, how we've been doing.
We have over 400 partners
who have used the Smart Home
API on Access on Google.
We hope that number goes
up and some of you guys
leave and start to
also create some
of these integrations for us.
The other cool part is we
control over 5,000 Smart Home
products on the market today.
So if you walk into any of
your favorite electronic stores
or any of your favorite sites
and look at the Smart Home
devices, there's a good chance
that the Google Assistant
actually can control it.
But we're seeing an evolution.
When we first started this,
I remember talking to David.
And we were all excited that
we can say, turn the light on,
turn the light off.
We were like, oh man, we did it.
We just changed the world.
This is our Edison moment.
But what we realized
very quickly
that on and off wasn't enough.
We wanted to be able
to have the user speak
to the Assistant in
the way that they speak
to their partner, their
spouse, or their children
or their family.
And this evolution is
a very simple thing
from saying turn the temperature
to 72 degrees versus make
it cooler, make it warmer.
And how do we achieve that?
The first step
that we took was we
decided to make sure that every
single device, we actually
support it directly so that we
had a deep understanding of how
that device works and what are
the actual traits that we need
to create so we can match
those to the grammars
that the user will
actually want.
So 2016, we had a
very small start.
We had four devices.
But you can see in 2017, we
brought so many new devices
to the market that
we support directly
and we understand
with deep knowledge
from cameras, doorbells,
washers and dryers, sensors,
air purifiers, refrigerators.
There's tons.
But we're not done.
There's a bunch more
in 2018 that we're
bringing, all the way
down to tubs and toilets.
There will be a day where
you talk to your tub,
believe it or not.
And there's a trait for that.
And David will
tell you about it.
But let me just walk you through
really quickly, how are we
using all this data?
How are we using AI?
How are we using machine
learning to actually create
a better user experience?
So this is a very simple graph.
But if you think about
this light, to the user,
to a five-year-old, they
point at it and say, mommy,
daddy, that's a light.
What we want to understand
about that light
is a little bit different.
We want to know what's
the name of that light?
What traits does it have?
Does it support on, off?
Does it support color,
brightness, state?
And where is its location?
Because that allows us to
take the right action when
a user says, make the
lights in the living room--
dim the lights in the
living room a little bit
or make the lights in
the living room brighter,
because what we're
doing is we're
going back to that Home Graph.
And we're saying what's
the name of that light?
Where is it located?
What's its current state?
What's its current brightness?
Oh, it's current
brightness is x.
We'll raise it by y.
This is how we are
starting to really take
this data that we're having
about the home and devices
and it's contextual awareness
and make it a better user
experience.
But it just doesn't
stop with lights.
Lights is easy.
Think about all the other
devices in your home.
So you'll be able
to say, hey Google,
raise the temperature
a little bit.
Hey Google, is the
front door locked?
Hey Google, do the laundry.
Hey Google, dry my clothes.
Or hey Google, start vacuuming.
Those last remind me a of
me being my mom's assistant.
It's like, hey, clean the house.
But these are the type
of things that we believe
you will start to see
from the Google Assistant,
because we've built
this really cool backend
with contextual understanding
about the location
and environment and deep
understanding devices.
To give you a little bit
more about how as a developer
you can take advantage
of this, David
will walk you through
Actions on Google.
DAVID SCHAIRER: Cool.
Thanks, Mark.
As Mark just noted,
we've spent the last year
really expanding this platform.
We launched it a
year ago at I/O.
We had at the time maybe
a dozen, 20 partners.
And now we're, as Mark
said, 400 partners,
5,000 device products.
We've also got tens of thousands
of developers playing with us.
And a little later,
I'm going to talk
about how we actually do that.
But first, I'm just going
to walk through a little bit
about how this works.
We do a cloud-to-cloud
integration.
So for most of our
partners in the IoT space,
they've already got a cloud.
They've got app control.
They've got devices that
are wired to their cloud.
And so it's very, very easy
to take that cloud integration
and plug it into
our lightweight API.
Most of our partners
here, we say,
integrate within six weeks.
That's end-to-end
from start of project
to launching the partners
and includes testing,
includes evaluation.
It includes whatever we need
to do to make sure everything's
good to go.
We have partners that
actually do the work
in under a day, because in many
cases, it's just that easy.
And as Mark said, I'll go
into a little more detail.
We use these concepts
called types and traits.
The reason we do
this-- we don't say,
this is the platonic
washing machine.
All washing machines aspire
to this ideal device.
Instead we say, there's
a type of device
called a washing machine.
[INAUDIBLE] it's a
washing machine type
tells us a little bit about it.
It lets us learn that we can
call it a washing machine.
We can make it look
like a washing machine.
A washing machine is like
a duck in that regard.
But that doesn't tell us what
that washing machine does,
because each washing
machine has its own state,
its own settings.
One of them has a permanent
press mode and one of them
doesn't.
One of them has steam, one
of them doesn't and so forth.
All of that is where
we go to traits.
And we use traits as
the building blocks
of the Smart Home.
And this lets partners
innovate in their own way,
in new ways, which is
what we did at our demo.
If you go to our sandbox, they
have a mailbox over there.
We have a somewhat dumber
mailbox here on stage.
I'm going to show you
how we built this later.
But this mailbox in the
sandbox, no one of our partners
has built a smart
mailbox before.
But we did this for the
demo, because all the traits
were there--
camera, light, on/off for the
light, the toggle for the flag,
object detection for mail.
Completely innovate new
device based on the existing
functionality we have.
And because we all put
this in the Home Graph
and the Home Graph understands
context, understands state,
understands change,
and as you can well
imagine a lot of the Google
secret sauce and machine
learning and intelligence
starts to operate
on the things we learned
from the Home Graph,
we start to be able to
take all of these devices
and actually truly make
the Smart Home smart.
All of this today you can
integrate with one API.
It's very simple.
And I'll show it to you later.
You integrate with the cloud.
You integrate a
couple of commands.
You let us query devices.
You let us execute devices.
You tell us the
devices are there.
You can call us back at any
time due to notifications,
to push estate changes,
to change the devices.
So that's all you do.
One little RESTful
[INAUDIBLE] API.
We have reference
limitations we'll show you
and lots of
documentation, a full team
of developer relations and
support engineers to help you.
And you don't need
to do grammar.
You don't need to do
internationalization.
You don't need to do UI.
Everything like that
is provided for you.
And as you can imagine,
with all the other devices
we're going to be rolling
out, that the same we do it
all for you happens on smart
displays and so forth as well.
So this is sort of the
status quo we're in today.
I'm going to turn
it back to Michele
to talk about the fun
stuff coming next.
MICHELE TURNER: Great.
Thanks, David.
So as Mark mentioned
and David mentioned,
we've spent the last couple
years building this platform
out.
And now we're in a
state where we're
able to add a lot
of new features
to really build on
the intelligence
and help you guys
create better and more
integrated and
interactive experiences.
At the end of the day,
what we all want to do
is create solutions to
problems that people
have in their homes, things that
they're going to use every day.
And so the fundamental
features that we're
adding over the
course of this year
are going to help you do that.
There are four main
features that we're adding
for the rest of this year--
something called Request
Sync, Report State,
New Object Detection Trait that
David is going to show you,
and some new things for
entertainment devices.
So let's start
with Request Sync.
Request Sync is
really very simple.
Right now, if I go
to the store and I
go buy another half dozen
smart lights to go put my home,
I have to add those devices.
And they don't
necessarily-- the fact
that I've added those
devices don't necessarily
get synced up onto the
partner app very quickly.
And so what we're doing with
Request Sync is you push
the state to the Google
Cloud to let us know--
actually it goes
into Home Graph--
to let us know that these new
devices have been on-boarded.
So I go out to the store.
I get my new devices
and screw them in.
I pair them up, get them
going, and they automatically
just work.
Today if I did that, I would
have to unlink and relink.
And that's a real
hassle for most users.
And so we've taken that
uncomfortable step out
for users, made
it easier for you,
and made it a lot easier
for your customers.
I think one of the most
painful points of Smart
Home for a lot of new users
is just getting started even
with things like lights.
So making that on-boarding
process simpler and easier
is really important.
And that's part of
what Request Sync does.
We've also added a new
API for Report State.
Report State is
really important.
And I'll tell you why it's
even more important than ever.
I've spent a lot of time
talking to a number of you
in the sandbox the
last couple of days
about why we need Report State.
So imagine a situation
where you go up
and you change your
thermostat on the wall.
Go up and shift
it from 65 to 72.
What we normally
do on the back end
is we pull you to
figure out when
that device has been updated.
But you guys all saw the new
displays and the new user
interfaces for the
phone in the keynote.
Well, now we have
new user interfaces
on these smart
displays and iPhones
that will show the devices.
And with Report State,
when you push Report State
to us and into
the Home Graph, we
can get that state
information instantly.
So there's no
cognitive dissonance
between I just went over
and changed my thermostat,
and my smart display is
still holding an old state
of temperature information.
So report state
is very important.
It's one of the
things we're starting
to require our
developers to give us
so that we make
sure that that user
experience for our
consumers is spot on.
The other reason you
want to use Report State
is so that we're not
polling you all the time,
which can get annoying and puts
a lot of load on your server,
especially if you have
very active devices.
In the future,
Report State is going
to allow us to unlock
a lot of intelligence.
The state information
that we can get,
we can work with you
together to start
creating more
intelligent experiences,
like understanding
that in the kid's room,
the light is turned out
every night at 7:30.
So maybe we should
just do that for you.
So Report State's
really important
now to make sure we have great
experiences for our consumers.
And it's going to be really
important in the future
as we start building more
and more intelligence.
So the next feature I
want to talk to you about
is Ob Detection.
And this is one of my favorites.
This is actually a trait.
We originally built this trait
actually a few months ago.
If you're familiar with the
Nest Hello video doorbell,
you may know this feature.
And it will actually let you
know someone's at the door.
And we did that integration
using the new object detection
trait.
Let's take a look.
See if I can--
there we go.
[NOTIFICATION TONE]
DEVICE VOICE: Someone's
at the front door.
MICHELE TURNER: So you
haven't seen that before.
Simple push of the button.
And it notifies out on
the Google Home Mini
through the Assistant.
What's really cool
about this trait
is that it actually
changes the model.
And this is one of
the things I really
want to stress
with you that we're
trying to do at Google is give
you guys the ability to create
more interesting integrations.
So with the Object
Detection trait,
normally the Assistant
controls the device.
You say, OK Google, turn
on the lights, right?
With this, you take
an action on a device,
and it tells the Assistant
to give a notification.
Oops, I just fired
the Assistant off.
Sorry.
So Dave is going to come
up right now and show you
a little bit more of what you
can do with object detection.
DAVID SCHAIRER: Cool, thanks.
So I'm going to do a demo here
of how notifications work.
Object detection is
actually a specific case
of a general facility we're
adding to the Smart Home
where partners can send
notifications on objects.
And notifications become another
aspect of objects and devices
that you push into
the Home Graph,
just like traits and attributes
and states and commands
and so forth are
aspects of devices.
In this case, notifications
attach to traits.
So just like in Java
where you have an object
and the object might
receive messages
and might declare
the errors it throws,
when you declare
a trait, you also
are saying, hey, for
example, this washing machine
supports a run cycle.
Therefore, it can now
send slash receive,
depending on your perspective,
notifications of cycle errors.
The washing machine has
failed during the rinse cycle.
We've built this--
object detection
is our first case of this.
And like the video
showed, we built it--
first use case is doorbells,
but we build these things
as general cases.
The example in the sandbox
is for mail detection.
And here we're going
to build something
a little more interesting.
But we're going to show you--
I'm going to go back,
recapitulate a little bit,
register a Smart Home project,
show how linking works,
show how you can deploy
your cloud service here
or elsewhere, how the
notifications are sent through
in this case Node.js and
Firebase from the device
itself, and finally
show you some code,
show you some debugging tools.
This is basically the
flow of this demo.
So this is a smart mailbox.
It's really a
pretty dumb mailbox.
But it has a very
smart Raspberry Pi
down there that has some
sensors wired into the box.
And again, not a
shipping product,
but easy demo that
is a make or you
can build something like this.
The mailbox has a cloud service
that we have on Firebase.
It sends a notification
in whatever protocol.
In this case, it's a GET
request to the payload
that this sends to
our Cloud Service.
Cloud Service is
where the smarts are.
also part of our API.
It calls the Assistant
with a One Platform API
call, sends notification.
The notification
then goes directly
to the Google Home
I have up here.
And we'll see that demo.
And of course, all of this
is driven by the fact that
initially-- and I'll show
you the code for this--
initially the mailbox
and other devices
were synced from
the partner service
to the Assistant
for my demo user.
And therefore, in
the home graph,
we know that this
device supports--
actually technically
it supports everything
that the one in the
sandbox does-- the flag,
the lights, the
camera and so forth.
There's actually no camera
in here, unfortunately.
But all the traits are there.
So I am going to
hop on-- whoops--
I'm going to hop on over
to the laptop screen
here, which of course
locked on me, and great.
So some of you saw
this last year.
We have rebuilt
this quite a bit.
Last year we were doing
a demo that was largely
at the command line.
You need no command line
functionality for this now.
Those of us like me that
missed the command line
are a little sad.
But for the vast
majority of people,
we are now entirely using the
Actions on Google Console.
So no more G actions,
writing action packages.
This is much more native for us.
So I'm just going to walk
through a very simple example.
And we're short on time.
So I'm going to do this very
quickly, of how you build
a Smart Home project today.
So I'm going to add a project.
Now if you're doing this,
you pick a project name.
Recommendation, pro tip from
what we've done with partners,
pick a name that makes sense.
We're no longer
auto-picking names for you,
so you don't get something
like Purple Chaos Giraffes.
Pick a name, because you're
going to be using this with us
later if you deploy
this to production.
So that said, let's call
this Purple Chaos Giraffes,
because why not?
And that creates--
spin, spin, spin,
very slow because I'm on stage.
And it knows I'm on stage,
so it's going to slow down.
This is creating a project in
the Actions on Google console
with my Google account up here.
And-- wow, it really is slow.
And now I have all these things.
This is the full Actions
on Google panoply.
So I can build a shopping app,
or I can build a chat app,
or I can build a
quote of the day app.
All of those are using
conversational actions.
But for Smart
Home, we are really
recommending and very
strongly recommending
that you're using these
APIs, because this
is what gives you Home
Graph and notifications
and full understanding.
And so today the setup
is in fact very quick.
To get up and
running, this is going
to take only a couple minutes.
So I'm going to name
this something random.
And I will then--
and forgive me, my network
is especially slow today--
account linking.
Many of you have
done this already.
OAuth is the mechanism
for account linking
to existing service clouds.
This is pretty standard OAuth.
Nothing out of
the ordinary here.
I'm going to make some
keyboard mash keys.
Do not use these keys at home.
And of course I don't--
that is protected by RFC.
Did you know there's an
actual RFC protecting
example.com in perpetuity?
No one ever knows
that, but it is real.
And Testing is Awesome.
And at this point, we
are pretty much set up.
We're going to go
ahead, create an action.
I am going to give it--
I need exactly one thing.
I need the end point
for the action.
And again, this is a demo.
I'm not going to
set this one up.
I'm going to switch to
the one I have set up.
And at this point, I
have now deployed this.
And this will show
up on my phone.
Actually, I'm not--
I have now deployed this.
And it will show up on my phone.
And it will complain,
because I don't
have a URL set up for OAuth.
But this is now
set up on my phone
and will be available in
a second to show that.
But instead I'm going
to switch back over here
to my staged demo project.
This is the one
we're actually using.
And here I've got
the action set up.
It's pointed at a Firebase app.
And the Firebase app here is--
I'm going to show
you the Firebase app.
You can deploy-- we get
asked this question a lot.
Do I need to use Google Cloud?
Do I need to use Android Things?
Do I need to use Weave?
Do I need to use Thread?
Google has, as Google always
does, a number of technologies
that you can use to be a
completely full-stack Google
Developer in everything you do.
And if you want to do
that, that is awesome.
But it is completely and
totally not required.
If you have an existing
cloud, you can keep it.
You can integrate this with any
infrastructure that you want.
You just need internet,
decent security, OAuth,
and our lightweight JSON API.
In this case, we've done
this demo using Firebase.
It's a Node.js app.
It's using the Firebase
database, as you can see,
to actually do all
the triggering.
You can see our
trigger types here,
our traits here right
now for object detection
and so on and so forth.
That is how we implement
in Firebase database
the actual representation
of the commands
that we run this through.
And so I'm now going to
show you a little code.
We have this implemented
as a Node.js application.
This application
is a slight variant
of the one that's
in the code lab.
So if you go over to the code
labs by the front of I/O,
there is a smart
home code lab that's
building a washing machine.
It is very much this code.
This is also on GitHub.
So you can see that you
can play with this yourself
and use this if you want as
a reference in limitation.
This is not a full--
you would not want
to use this as it
is for your IoT
product in market,
because it doesn't have
a persistent database.
It doesn't have a lot
of the user handling
that you'll want for
obviously your own product.
But it does [INAUDIBLE]
and limitation, including
a lot of these traits here.
And so just to show you a little
bit, what we're going to demo
here is primarily object
detection like Michele said.
But instead of doing mail,
because these things are
extensible, I'm
going to show you
how you might build a
product that detects,
like in my neighborhood,
we have some other needs
for this sort of thing.
And I'll show you
how that works.
But first, let me show
you how you declare this.
So we have a sync handler.
The sync handler is basically
just-- this is all Node.js.
It's simply building
the payload.
That's actually
remarkably uninteresting.
The device list here in the
reference is building devices.
So this is a fixed list.
You run this.
And because it's
in the database,
it defines a number
of objects for you
that you can use for tests.
Here's, for example,
a washing machine.
As I was saying,
this washing machine
implements on/off and start/stop
and modes and toggles.
So it's going to have modes
for permanent press, hot/cold.
It's going to have toggles
probably for quiet mode
or bleach mode or whatever.
And it has a sensor built in.
And then we've built down
here somewhere a mailbox.
Of course, [INAUDIBLE].
And here you can see these
are all the traits that we
have used, including the
outgoing mail toggle here
is a toggle.
We just have a
special code for it,
because you have to do
attributes for toggle.
This is all the
things that the light
in the box and the
sensor and the flag
and the detection in the
camera screen support.
And to see all of these in
action, go to the sandbox
where the camera is
working and the flag
is working and so forth.
And with that, let me
show you the notification.
Notification in this case,
again, Node.js, very simple.
It's taking a pass
through from the payload,
from HTTP endpoint
to the box calls
our implementation in Firebase.
And it simply then has--
ignore the hack line.
It simply sends
this notification
back through the
report [INAUDIBLE]
reports data notifications
use the same call.
This uses a Java web token
to call us at any time.
It's how you do sync.
It's how you do state reporting.
And it's how you
do notifications.
And so this is running.
It's running in Firebase.
I am going to show
you-- if you can switch
to my phone for just a second.
First I'm going to show you--
I've already set this
up, so I've already
connected to this agent.
You can see I've got
all the virtual devices
that this one advertises, which
are the devices in the sandbox.
But I've got the mailbox here.
[INAUDIBLE] no commands
on the mailbox right now.
But I want to show
you object detection.
Object detection in
this case, like I
said, we implemented--
instead of doing mail,
we implemented animal detection,
because object detection can
detect anything, doorbell
face recognition, whatever.
This was supposed to be
originally a live demo,
a live animal demo.
But our lawyers said no,
that was a liability.
And I was being
grossly irresponsible.
So I'm afraid this is no
longer a live animal demo.
But could I get that mic
turned on on the Google Home?
Thanks.
So not a live animal demo.
I apologize.
But if all works well--
[NOTIFICATION TONE]
DEVICE VOICE: There's a
raccoon in the mailbox.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID SCHAIRER: So
kind of a lame--
[APPLAUSE]
--kind of a lame demo where
we're using the detection
logic for mail.
And it's a little
harder on fuzzy animals,
because it's not fuzzy logic.
So it's a little tricky there.
But you can see, just like with
the Nest facial recognition,
which to be fair is
many, many, many more
thousands of engineering hours
of time than that raccoon demo,
but you can see you
as an IOT partner can
do what you do best.
You build a cool device.
And we'll handle all the
grammar, the understanding,
the notifications which
go to now you have access
to the ecosystem in the house.
You don't just send
messages to the phone.
You can do notifications
around the house
of interesting things.
And we'll see over the
coming weeks and months,
we'll be adding notifications
of a lot of different types
to existing traits for
security events, safety
events, other notifications.
You can imagine, when the
oven timer is going off,
you're in the other room.
You want to know
the roast is done.
Those sorts of
notifications are available.
And you can now be [INAUDIBLE]
into the Smart Home ecosystem.
And these are things that will
be rolling out significantly
over the coming months.
Like I said, this reference
example by and large
and minus the raccoon
is in the sandbox.
You can do this with
all of our ecosystems.
You can run it on--
this is on Firebase.
Run it on your own cloud.
Run it on--
I know some other companies
out there have clouds.
I forget their names.
But you can run it wherever
you like on your existing
infrastructure.
You can run anything
you want on your client.
We do have Android Things.
And you should
absolutely-- in this space,
you should go and see the
Android Things sandbox.
There's some very cool stuff.
We have some cool projects
where you can easily
integrate Android Things with
the Smart Home ecosystem.
We'll be doing a
lot more of that.
Someone just showed
me this walk through.
This actually last year.
But this walk
through you can find
by searching for home
automation and Android Things.
Somebody did a very easy walk
through demo of Android Things
running directly with the API.
And you can do
that walk through.
We also have several
open source projects
natively integrated today.
So over here we have Home
Assistant somewhere--
where are there?
Home Assistant right there
in the middle hash.io.
And we have
[INAUDIBLE] which are
both right there in the
middle, which are both open
source platforms that
are already integrated.
So if you want to play
with smart home devices
and don't want to
implement this awesome API,
you can use those for
your project as well.
And the last thing I wanted
to show in a developer tool,
because this is
something that we've
been asked for extensively
in the last few months,
six months, is we have
done a lot more work
to integrate developer
tools into the Google
ecosystem for smart home.
So this here is the Stackdriver.
Can you switch
back to the laptop?
Thank you.
So this here--
it's hard to read,
I apologize-- is the
Stackdriver for this account.
So here's the [INAUDIBLE] demo.
I've logged into Stackdriver.
And all of the errors
that we see on our side,
and I had to generate
some yesterday to get
this or last week,
all of these errors
are things that you would
not see because they're
outside of your ecosystem.
If we make a call to the
mailbox and hit your server,
the mailbox fails, you know.
But if an open auth is
failing, if sync data is wrong,
if the notification
that you send
can't be delivered after
you've given it to us,
all of those things
are errors that we
don't have real time reporting.
So they're now going
into Stackdriver.
You can integrate this
with your service.
You can use this with debugging.
You can Pub/Sub from Stackdriver
if you have another logging
service.
You can subscribe to
your Stackdriver alerts,
directly integrate
them with your logging.
And all of that is now available
and highly recommended,
makes the development
process much easier.
That's really
end-to-end on the demo.
Like I said, please visit
the Smart Home sandbox.
We have lots more
demos like this there.
Talk to us.
We have our development team
ready to support developers.
We have folks answering
questions online.
We have other events like this.
And throw us your questions.
We have a dedicated team of
folks just building new traits,
building new device
support every day.
We have a lot of stuff
that is available,
but not yet on the
public website.
So if you see something that
you want, it's not there,
talk to us.
It's probably something we've
already built. And if not,
we'll probably build it for you.
So talk to us.
And with that, I
will turn it back
to Michele for one more thing.
MICHELE TURNER: One more thing.
Thanks, Dave.
That was awesome.
Does the raccoon have a name?
DAVID SCHAIRER: Sorry?
MICHELE TURNER: Does
the raccoon have a name?
DAVID SCHAIRER: The
raccoon's name is Craig.
MICHELE TURNER: Craig?
DAVID SCHAIRER: Yes.
We spent significant
time on this yesterday.
MICHELE TURNER: Excellent.
We'll get the back story later.
So we do have one more thing.
So we are announcing
here that we are also
opening up new APIs for control
of entertainment devices.
And if you've been
to the sandbox,
you've probably seen
the demo that we
have in the booth of
the Dish Hopper box
that's currently
working in there.
That's our first implementation.
It'll be launching
in a few weeks.
We'll take a quick look
at it for those of you
who haven't been there yet.
MARK SPATES: OK, Google.
Switch to HGTV on the Hopper.
MICHELE TURNER: So there we go.
It switched to HGTV.
MARK SPATES: OK, Google.
Switch to ESPN on the Hopper.
MICHELE TURNER:
By the way, that's
Mark's and my cool little setup
in our office of the mini Smart
Home.
So these new media or
entertainment device APIs
are meant for devices
that aren't Android TV
and are not cast enabled.
And there's millions
of them out there,
like the one in my
living room that's
a smart TV that has
no voice interface.
There's no mic.
There's no speaker.
And what we want to be able to
do is light up the Assistant
to make home control easier
for those types of devices.
So what we've done is we've
announced a set of traits.
And this is the
list of traits we
have specific to
entertainment devices.
So we have transport control
gives you the ability
to move the media, rewind,
fast forward, et cetera,
change the volume up and down,
get the state of the media,
do recording, understand
what channel you're on.
You just heard Mark
switching to the channels.
We played a lot
of ESPN yesterday.
And in some cases, we are
also doing media initiation.
And this is by early
access partner only.
So if you happen to
be at a company that's
doing entertainment devices,
please come talk to us.
We'll be in the sandbox
and happy to talk
to you more about this.
One other thing that I wanted to
mention in addition to our APIs
and just touch on
lightly, this was slightly
covered in the
keynote, but we now
have a number of surfaces in
which your smart devices will
be shown, so not only
through voice control
on a variety of speakers,
but now on the phone.
You'll have the
new Assistant app
that will show the status of
your smart device on the phone
and also on all of the
new intelligent displays.
So multiple surfaces
for your smart device
to be displayed on
and interacted with.
So Mark mentioned this earlier
that we're up to 400 partners
and over 5,000 devices.
These are just some
of the partners
that we've launched since
CES, which was in January.
So we're growing very fast.
We've added new partners like
LG, Dish, Hisense, Vivint,
Xiaomi, Panasonic.
A huge variety of partners
have been coming on
with really interesting
integrations.
So if you're thinking about
getting started in Smart Home,
please come talk to us.
As David mentioned,
we are in the sandbox.
We're in the Google
Assistant sandbox,
which is tent A. We also have a
code lab going where you can go
try this out for yourself,
do some of the coding
that David just did, get your
basic project up and going.
If you are already a developer
with us at the Smart Home
and want to understand
more about report state,
we've got a code
lab on that as well.
And we will be hanging out
in the sandbox after this.
So please come and talk to us.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]